we are just hearing a development here
in Nottingham after these appalling
attacks in the early hours of uh this
morning after which a 31 year old man
was arrested and is now in custody and
we're hearing first of all we heard uh
earlier this afternoon from the
University of Nottingham that two of its
students had been killed in the attacks
we then heard from the police that they
were both aged 19 years old well now the
Press Association is reporting that one
of those students is confirmed to be 19
year old Barnaby Weber Barnaby Weber
believed to have been a very keen young
cricketer who played for Bishop's Hull
Cricket Club in Taunton also we're told
played for the Nottingham
University cricket team but that
development tonight the first
identification of a victim of these
appalling attacks Barnaby Weber that's
according to the Press Association
Martin brand is with me here our crime
correspondent so
um we now know one of the
victims a family and friends mourn of
course that just bring us up to date
though with what we know about what's
happened
we know that three people have died
Barnaby Weber one of the first two to
die he and a fellow students were they
just left a nightclub called Bodega
um about four o'clock in the morning
when they apparent apparently were the
random victims of a stabbing attack so
he and the other students were stabbed
in the streets and died
sometime later the same suspect police
believe
um attacked a man
the owner of a van stabbed that man to
death man in his 50s left him in the
street and took his van and then used
that van in the city center near the
theater Royal to Ram three more victims
um one or more who we think were
standing near a bus stop and they were
hurt they were injured one of them
critically still in hospital tonight
critically injured the other two
suffered minor injuries so I think
detectives must be hopeful that they
will be in a position to give some
details about the nature of their attack
now I think tonight it's beginning to
look
much more like this is a criminal act
for whatever reason rather than a terror
attack police have acknowledged that
counter-terror officers have been
working alongside them that's not
unusual it's a very big complex
investigation
counter-terror units are some of the
best resourced in the country for
obvious reasons in the past few years
but I'm told tonight we understand that
some of those countertery officers who
are from the kind of main UK pool of
investigators have been withdrawn and
the local CT officers counter-terror
officers who are largely an intelligence
unit they stay beside working beside the
Nottingham detectives so again I think
that's an indication that this is
although police still say they're
keeping an open mind about the very
about the motives it's moving much more
towards Criminal